Not been the easiest weekend in
my life or my careers last week,
but hanging in there to make this a
standalone so that people don't have to go
figuring this out on their
own. And I'm sure many,
many fans are tuning in already
know that the gist of the details,
let's lay this out from the beginning.
John Jones initial failed test.
Yeah.
So that was July of 2017 he tested
positive for approximately 20,
anywhere from 20 to 60 Pega grams of a
longterm metabolite known as the three
metabolite of a substance called
dihydro chloral methyl testosterone,
D, H, C M, T, also known
as oral to rentable.
And this was over a year ago. Um,
what was determined to be
the source of this stuff,
never determined what the source was.
So John went through a full
arbitration hearing, um,
was never able to determine
where it came from,
tested all the supplements he was
using, you know, went through many, uh,
interviews with USADA, had a
full on arbitration hearing. Uh,
the source was never
determined where it came from.
Why was his suspension so low
or so short? Well, I mean,
he wasn't determined.
So I mean there's many factors that
go into what that suspension was.
I w I would argue in the total totality
of the evidence that was presented in
that arbitration, that it, that
it wasn't a short suspension. Um,
because really one key thing
came out at arbitration.
So John went to arbitration before an
individual by the name of Richard McLaren.
Richard McLaren has an arbitration group
up in Canada and McLaren is probably
worldwide known as one of the
most credible guys in anti-doping.
I know you had the Icarus
producer director on the
McLaren report was the report
that came from all that.
He basically investigated the Russian
state being involved in doping and Sochi
games and put out actually
a series of reports on it,
detailing that up to 1000
Russian athletes. Um, you know,
we're breaking the rules and the Russian
laboratory was helping them get around
it. So he's a very, very respected guy.
He's independent of obviously the
UFC. He's independent of USADA.
Um, he acts on his own and his
determination was his determination. Um,
and I'll read you kind
of what he said. He said,
I find that all evidence available to me
leads me to conclude that the violation
was not intended,
nor could it have enhanced
the athlete's performance.
So a non-intentional, so
non-intentional ingestion.
I mean there's no argument
that it was in his system,
but he found the evidence
to show non-intentional use.
And then he went further saying that
based on the numbers of what he saw in the
evidence that was not even a performance
enhancing benefit afforded to John for
having this longterm
metabolite in his system.
And I think that's significant when
you talk about Hey 15 was that, that's,
you know, kind of light being that
this is the second time through.
I would argue that if there was an
argument that maybe it's on the higher end
and certainly, you know, we'll talk
about the California commission.
Andy foster took that position, uh,
in John's recent California hearing,
he was a little bit critical of
USADA. Um, he thought, you know,
he's intimately familiar with his evidence
both in the previous case and this
occurrence that,
and he also saw that there was no
evidence that an independent arbitrator,
you know, made this, uh, statement and
decision of John intentionally cheating.
Um, so if anything, you know,
I'd say that potentially there could be
an argument that, that it was, you know,
on the higher end versus the lower
end because of the fact that it was an
unintentional ingestion. Exactly.
What is John's excuse? What is,
what is John said how he got this
into his system. We'll look, you know,
it's detailed in the arbitration hearing
at all. John John fully admits that,
you know, some of the lifetime lifestyle
decisions he was making, you know,
the partying and things, you
know, probably did not lead to,
to making smart decisions and making
smart choices in terms of what was being
ingested in the body.
But certainly his testimony was under
oath that I have never intentionally
cheated and did not intentionally
put this substance in my body.
And not only this case, but as we
talk about the subsequent case here,
I think you'll see that based
on the numbers, you know,
coming out of his tests and based on some
studies that have been done on some of
these substances, it would tend to support
that. Okay, correct me if I'm wrong,
but didn't John test negative then test
positive for extremely low numbers?
This is the initial test before we
get into the most recent field test.
He did test negative then test positive
very shortly after with a very small
trace amount. Correct. So you had two
negative tests on July 7th and July 8th,
I believe, of 2017 and then way in day,
I think it was July 28th,
he was positive for a very low
level of the [inaudible] metabolite.
And we might as well start here. So
again, going back to Icarus, remember,
remember the doctor,
I mean he's the main character in that
were Cenk of in 2011 he put out a study
on oral Toronto ball. Um, he actually,
my understanding is dosed himself and
then studied the excretion of his urine.
And what was coming out of it over the
weeks and months after and determined
that there was multiple,
maybe up to 50 metabolites,
that once this DH CMT was
ingested into the body,
the body converted into other substances
and these metabolites stayed around.
He identified some short term metabolites,
some medium term metabolites,
and some longterm metabolites,
specifically the M three that
John's tested positive for it.
So these longterm metabolites
would indicate that it
was taken a long time ago.
They would stay around
for the longest. Why?
Why was testing negative and then testing
positive for these extremely. So yeah,
that numbers, that's a
good question. And that's,
that's basically the question and point.
But what was not occurring and what has
never occurred in any of John's samples
is any presence of the short
and medium term metabolites.
And if you look at a rich Dankoff study,
he identifies a couple of
these medium term metabolites,
Roman numeral one and Roman numeral two
and he says these metabolites based on
his study will stay in the
body at least 22 days. W, well,
let's look back to the July 7th and
eighth you know, positive tests.
He's negative on July 7th and eighth
for everything. For the parent compound,
for the short term,
medium term term metabolites and the
longterm metabolites go 2021 days later.
So within that 22 day window,
which is study shows the short and
medium term metabolites would still be
showing up and there's no presence
whatsoever of the short or medium term
metabolites. Now again, we'll
get into this a little bit more,
but I think the science,
what it's showing is a pulsing
effect for this longterm metabolite.
Meaning once you ingest,
whether intentionally or
not unintentionally oral
torrented ball into the body,
the body breaks it down, produces short
term and medium term, which is you know,
visible for a short and
medium amount of time.
And then this [inaudible] which is
produced for a long period of time,
I think with the issue appears
to be, and we'll get into this,
the UFC program is not the
only program that seen this.
There's another professional sports
league that has seen it very frequently.
You saw it as also seen
this on the Olympic side,
but we're seeing this strange action
with the longterm and three metabolite.
And the theory is it may be hiding, um,
in the fat tissues surrounding organs and
maybe have a pulsing effect where it's
released at certain times and
other times you can't detect it.
And this is not the actual substance
itself, but it's a metabolite correct.
Which indicates a reaction
to this substance indicates
the body breaking down.
Okay.
The parent compound the oral terenna ball
and turning it into these other things
which are stored in the body.
So those metabolites are not performance
enhancing drugs that are the result of
the breakdown of the
parent drug in the body.
How much time is it detectable,
the actual drug itself?
So pretty quick, uh, it's a
pretty quick clearance time.
I think we're chunk off study
says, you know, maybe a week. Uh,
so it's not around for very long and
that's why he conducted the study
ironically enough.
And I was going to go watch
bickers here last night and I just,
I've had too much going on in the last
week to kind of refresh my mind. But, um,
apparently he, he knew this was part
of his protocol for Russian athletes.
He knew a coach that was still giving
the oral Taranto ball to Russian athletes
and he had a falling out with the coach.
So he goes off on the side and Hey the
parent compounds going to get in and out
of the body pretty quick. It's going
to be difficult to detect that.
Let's try to figure out what stays around
and leaves markers in the body for a
long time.
And so he developed these short and
longterm metabolite tests and was able to
catch some of this coaches athletes for
using the oral to rentable. Interesting.
So the actual drug itself
has gone from the system,
but the metabolite remains now
what is the window that the,
this metabolite is supposed
to be detectable in the body?
Cause we're talking now, what do we
at like 18 months? So here's the,
here's the problem. Was
that initial ingestion? Yep.
Cause my question is these
same longterm metabolites,
these existed a year plus
ago. It was more than a year.
How long ago that that's so
July, 2017 was your initial test.
So with all the experts,
and we'll get through this with all the
experts are telling us is that there is
no evidence of re ingestion and most
likely this is still remnants from the
July, 2017 tests. However it
was to enter into a system.
And we'll go through some of these
testing numbers that have shown negatives
followed by very low level Peka
Peka gram quantities. You know,
was that the ingestion that happened that
he tested positive for in July of 2017
indicated a longterm effect rate.
It was a longterm term metabolite,
correct. So meaning it had already
been assistant for a year or so.
It absolutely could
have predated, you know,
the theory the first time through was
something had to have entered his system
between July 7th and July
8th those negatives and this
low peak gram reading on
July 28th over this last year,
there's been a lot of study into this
longterm metabolite. As I mentioned,
this isn't just a UFC issue.
There's another major professional sports
league that for the time being wants
to keep their, their testing confidential,
but they've shared that information with
scientists, with USADA, with myself.
They saw it on multiple
occasions as pulsing effect
over a year where you'd see,
but this is positive. Tell over a year.
We're talking two and a half years now,
right. If it's a year, if it's a,
if in July he had July, 2017 you were
talking a year and a half, right?
July, 2017 correct.
July 17 but it could have been in his
system a year prior. I don't know. Yeah,
it could have been a couple of
months a year. I don't know.
He'd never showed up for that N three
metabolite four you'd been tested for it.
He had been tested multiple times in the
programming from wrong isn't the same
level, isn't it?
Approximately the same Pika grams that
exists today in 2018 that were there in
2017 generally if you look and
we can go over these numbers, it,
it fluctuates, you know,
from single digits and never gets into
triple digits to mid double digit.
So there is some as low as nine
peak grams over that time. Um,
there was some at 60 Pika grams, however,
a peak of gram to someone because it's
a preposterously small. It's insane.
And you know the, the analogy
that I heard early on was,
and I think John uses throw a pinch of
salt in Olympic swimming pool and I'm
like, okay, well that's kind
of wrap your head around.
Now let's go the other side.
Let's talk about something really small
that we know of and how many times you
have to break down that small
particle to get to a peak of gram.
So one grain of salt. I mean, we all
know what that looks like, right?
You put that in front of you and you
split that. And I had mentioned this week,
50 million, it's actually 58 million.
If you split that 58 million times the
grain installed each one as a Pika gram.
I mean it's in comprehensible,
the detection level and how
small that is. It really is.
It's crazy. And how many Pico
grams did they find in his system?
So he's gone from, and I'll, I'll
read through it here. So here's,
here's since the initial appearance
of the N three metabolite,
here's what John's tests look
like and those Pico gram readings.
So the first one was
collection date was July 28th,
2017. He had a concentration
of 80 Pika grams.
However, let me caution, and I'll
read something from, from an expert.
When you get down to
these picogram levels, um,
the science is somewhat in exact
because it's such a small amount.
So the variable, the plus or minus,
you know, can be anywhere from 2030.
I've seen in some instances 50 or
60. So what this scientist's name?
His name is Larry Bowers. Um, he was
formerly the, the USADA science director.
He's currently retired and
independently consults.
Before that he ran an Olympic,
uh, Olympic committee,
uh, accredited laboratory at
the university of Indiana.
The guy who's got 20 to 25
years of anti-doping experience.
Here's what he, he told me
about, uh, you know, when you're,
when you're analyzing
small picogram levels,
although the two lab, uh,
respective laboratories
report a concentration,
I would caution against becoming
too fixated on the numbers. First,
the numbers are really estimates of
concentration and probably should be
considered a range of about plus
or minus 20 picograms per ML.
And he said that December 9th result
would be in the range of John's a.
We'll get to that between 60 and a
hundred second while the adjustment of
concentration by specific gravity
attempts to deal with the variability of
urinary excretion rates, it is an exact,
it is inexact and adds variability
to the estimates. Finally,
most importantly,
science has no clear understanding of the
variance of urinary excretion of drugs
that alter trace concentration.
So basically saying, look,
I mean we have a general idea
how this works in science, but,
and I think this instance comes to play,
be real careful if you're going to be
the guy with the pseudoscience out there
saying, wait a second,
John jumped from 20 to 60 from September
to December and that means he re
ingested it. What he is saying
here is slow your roll on that.
That that it's such a small
in comprehensible level
that we don't really know
what those variances are
going to look like. Now,
I think if we saw jumps and John from
single single-digit eight or nine Pika
gram to multiple hundred digit Pika grams,
there would be a concern and maybe
some [inaudible] administration,
but the experts I've speaking to,
when you're talking variability of 10
2030 40 it's not that significant at the
peak of gram level.
What is the window where this longterm
metabolites starts to express itself?
Like what you said, there's short
term and there's medium term.
This is the longterm. How long
does it take before the launch?
That's a good question. I
don't have the answer to that.
It may be in [inaudible] report here and
I would encourage those that are home,
you know, playing playing scientist
at, at their computer. Uh,
the journal of steroid biochemistry
and molecular biology, uh,
raw chink OV writes report
detection and mass spec
spectrometric characterization of
novel longterm dehydro chloro method,
testosterone metabolites and human urine.
I'm not sure when that
longterm metabolite, how
long it takes to to show up.
Here's the problem though with this
substance. He did a real brief study.
My understanding is
administered it to himself.
That's the only study that
exists. Oral Taranto ball,
D, H C M T to my understanding is not
approved for use for human consumption
consumption anywhere,
anywhere in any country.
So you can't have clinical
trials ethically in the
medical world because it's
just not legal to give this
to human beings. So, you know,
we're, we're already kind of behind
the eight ball here and that, you know,
as compared to other substances where
you can do clinical trials cause they're
readily available via prescription
or whatever, this substance is not,
the substance was created by the East
Germans in the seventies and eighties and
was part of their state sponsored doping
program where they were doping their
athletes. Can you correct me if I'm wrong,
but I believe what I've read is that this
is particularly effective when people
are cutting weight. Yeah. I mean
is that true or is this just more,
I don't know about that. I
think some may be confusing.
Torrential with oral Toronto ball,
two completely different substances
actually very important. Yeah. There's,
there's very different
effects on the body.
There's very different windows in terms
of detection time ex explain that. Yeah.
You gotta be really careful in this
world of performance enhancing drugs.
There's names that are interchangeable.
There's different, you know,
chemical names where you change a
little bit of that chemical name.
It could mean me in a
completely different substance.
There's instances where the
chemical name is different,
but the substance is actually the same.
So when trying to compare
two substances, you know,
make sure if you're at
home doing that analysis,
you're comparing the right ones straight
to rent a ball is different than oral
to rentable. What is the difference?
Uh, yeah, I can't tell you,
I'm not as familiar with Toronto ball
other than it's not oral to rentable. So,
but there is a difference in terms the
detection window. Yeah, there would be,
I mean different substances create and
throw out different metabolites. Um,
and different substances have
different detection windows.
So I haven't done my study in research
on straight to rent a ball other than
knowing it's different than
the substance here. So, uh,
Gregory Richie Dankoff that's
how you say his last name, right?
He was the only guy to do an
actual verified study. Correct.
Know? Is this study been, is it been peer
reviewed? Yeah, I mean it will. It's,
it's published in
the journal of steroid
biochemistry and molecular biology.
So in order to get something published,
it needs to be peer reviewed.
So th it's, has it been replicated
anywhere? Not that I'm aware of. No.
So it's just so we have one study
which is really fascinating, right?
So we know that first of all, we
know this is an effect of steroids.
We know it works. Yeah. They use Germans
I think showed that they wouldn't be a,
had been using it. Um, it, it's
not a difficult, it's not a easy,
easy substance to get ahold of. Look,
when it's not approved for
use anywhere in the world, um,
it's only available on
the black market. Um,
so you probably have to go to China
to get it manufactured or, you know,
research chemical supply company.
It's not supposed to be provided to,
to humans. Now, I'm certainly
not attributing this to you,
but there were rumors,
this was one discussion.
Was that one of the possible
ways he could have ingested this,
um, and this be very kind,
John likes to party. Okay.
One of the things about
partying is people do cocaine.
One of the things about cocaine is
sometimes cocaine is cut with Creotine.
One of the things about creatine is
oftentimes you're buying cheap. Creatine.
I spent a little, one of the things
that we've had with on it on, it's our,
our products are all third party
verified, but in the initial goings,
when we tried different, uh,
manufacturers, especially for alpha brain,
we found there were other trace elements
that were in alpha brain that weren't
supposed to be in there.
And it's because of the vats that
they mix these things up with.
And one of the things that we had heard
was that creatine oftentimes is made in
the same place where they might
be making oral terenna ball.
They might be making antibodies,
they might be making a bunch of different
things and trace amounts of this stuff
can get into the creatine. They use
creatine to cut cocaine with, is this,
is this possible or am I just, yeah,
it's, it's absolutely a theory. I don't,
you know, I, I can't sit
here and said that happen,
but I will have heard similar
things. I have heard similar things.
I know for a fact, based
on my previous career,
I worked closely with the
DEA. I was with the FDA.
I worked cases involving street
distribution of recreational drugs,
including cocaine.
I know for a fact that 10 is one of the
most common substances that cocaine is
cut with because of the more little look.
Yeah, some more color, some more feel.
So getting back to McLaren's
arbitration decision, I mean this,
this is publicly available records,
so I'm not saying anything new,
but McLaren addresses at least
John's lifestyle around this time.
And he says the athlete openly admitted
to USADA that prior to and for period of
time after the reporting of his second
adverse analytical finding on July 28
2017, the athlete used elicit
so-called street drugs,
including cocaine. Now for
me to sit here and say, Hey,
that's where it came from.
I don't know that that's the time
period he's talking about the,
the athlete admitted, um,
that prior to and for a period of time
after the reporting of his second adverse
analytical finding on
July 27, 2017 admitted.
So before that test and
sometime after. Okay.
So does that make sense though?
If it's cut, if that's what,
where the source of it is,
does it make sense that that would
show up as a longterm metabolite?
Doesn't it need a long time in the body
to digest or do we not know enough about
the window of time? Yeah.
I don't know if we know enough about
the window of time, you know, my,
my theory and looking at it is even
if there's a small amount of the oral
terenna ball in that it's going to
for a period of time show that parent
compound at a small peak of gram amount
and the short and midterm metabolites in
the small Pika gram amount.
We have never seen those in
the history of John's testing.
It's only this longterm metabolite.
So that may be indication
that it occurred.
Maybe even prior to what
we're talking about here.
Is it something that could be accentuated
in some way by the weight cutting
process? I absolutely think
that could be a factor. Um,
there is studies not
necessarily with this, but, uh,
another substance clomiphene and look,
I want that while I'm cautioning people
to be careful about comparing different
substances. The commonality
between clomiphene,
which there are multiple clinical studies
on cause it is approved for use to be
distributed to humans and oral terenna
ball is they're both chlorinated.
So they both contain a
chlorine atom on the molecule.
And there is a recently published study
on clomiphene and its excretion rates.
Um, again for those at home
that want to look it up.
The study was published in the
endocrine society publication.
It's pure reviewed.
The name of it is HPT access effects and
urinary detection following clomiphene
administration and males. So what
they did is they basically, you know,
got a group of males, um, gave
them, uh, a one month, um,
cycle of clomiphene, you know,
I think 25 milligrams a day and then had
them get off and then continue to look
at their urine up to 261 days after.
And what you saw and what you see in
this study is that pulsing effect.
So, you know, I'm looking at some
of the study subjects here. Um,
subject one on day one 21 still
showed a 147 Pika grams of clomiphene.
Day one 28 showed a 174 Pika grams.
Day one 35 shows nothing.
He's below the minimum
coating reporting limit.
And then day one 49 he's back
up to two 36 there are one,
two, three, four, five,
six out of I think 12 subjects in that
study that showed this pulsing effect of
this chlorinated substance coming
and going again. You know, it's,
it's different than oral torrented ball,
but it has that common factor of
being chlorinated in this study.
They do talk about, I'm
a fat tissue called the,
let me look this up and make sure
I got this right. Adipose tissue,
this is fat that surrounds
the internal organs.
It's one of the last things that the
body burns when it's going, you know,
starving itself and going to fat.
It protects those organs. But yeah,
you look at these, you know,
extreme weight gains and cuts
that the UFC athlete goes through.
I don't think you're going
to find possibly another
human subject anywhere that
goes through putting weight on
other than cutting wrestling, maybe.
I don't think Olympic wrestling
matches with an MMA fighter. Um,
goes through at least, you know,
in my experience over these three or four
years talking to those in the Olympic
world. I think we're at
the extreme and it's,
it's something obviously we've talked
about before, we're trying to curtail,
but you know, there's,
there's clearly never been a study for
anybody who dehydrates and ReadWrite
hydrates themselves to the extent
that some of our athletes do.
You can never find that would never
be anybody with any ethics that would
support a study because some of that
dehydration exceeds world health
organization standards. So there's
no studies out there, you know,
on this stuff. But clearly,
you know, looking from afar I,
I'd say that it likely has some impact
over what's being released by this
adipose tissue. We should certainly talk
about that in the future, about the,
the weight cutting aspect of it.
So th but this adipose tissue loss at
extreme weight cuts could potentially be
the reason why this stuff
is excluding itself.
It's definitely a theory out
there. What about micro-dosing?
So here's the thing with micro-dosing
micro-dosing is done with endogenous
substances. So only test it. Well, I mean,
someone could try it with something else,
but the reason you microdose with
endogenous substances is they're already
produced in the body. Right?
So the theory of, okay,
I'm going to microdose oral terenna ball,
will oral Toronto balls still producing
the short term and longterm metabolites
in theory,
whether you're taking a hundred milligrams
or one milligram of oral torrented
ball,
those excretion rates of those metabolites
are still going to be consistent.
They're going to be in
a much smaller level,
a way to bypass those excretion rates.
Is there a way to mask that in some way?
I'm not aware of any
IPOs. Go ahead. I'm sorry.
The only study we have is Gregory.
Correct? That's it. Correct. But you know,
just taking it from a common
sense approach, it's, you know,
those that know about micro grossing
know that you microdose with endogenous
substances,
things that are already appearing in the
body so your body knows what to do with
them, knows what to do and
you're fooling, you know,
not only are these metabolizing
and there's no metabolites of them,
but you could also be fooling
the biological passport.
That's the concern I think
and why people microdose.
So you saw it as looking not only
testing for specific substances,
but our testosterone
epitestosterone ratios going up.
They're looking at at blood values,
how many young red blood cells,
how many mature red blood cells.
So microdosing in those two areas
wouldn't set off alarms in the biological
passport world. Um,
I'd never heard personally of microdosing
of exotic substances that are not
found in the body.
Microdosing in my understanding has done
with things that are indogenous body
for people that are not
familiar with this terminology,
we're just talking about microdosing
performance enhancing drugs because a
microdosing in today's world is a very
common thing with mushrooms and LSD and a
lot of right.
I mean I saw a ton of microdosing in
the cycling world that was testicles,
testosterone, EPO, H HGH, H, all
those natural occurring in the body.
And so they don't produce any
really a red flag metabolites.
If you do them at very,
very small levels, they'll,
the parent will clear quickly not produce
any metabolites and will not throw off
the biological passport analysis. Um,
is there a what you mean when Victor
Kanye came out with a clear and all that
stuff with BALCO, they were
fooling people. Is it, is it,
I mean one of the things that we've talked
about before is that it's a constant
race to try to keep up with more
advanced cheaters. It is. And you know,
what's interesting in this,
I mean without a talk to you and maybe
the first time we did talk a couple of
years ago, um, it, it's
come a long way from them,
but clearly if I would
have talked to you 15, 16,
17 years ago when I got my
start in the anti-doping world,
I would have told you definitively
the testing is way behind, you know,
what's being used out there.
Um, they were testing,
able to test to multiple
nanogram, um, limits.
That's as far down as we can go. Now they
can go down to single digit Pika gram.
There's another professional sports
league out there that recently had a one
Pika gram and three metabolite case.
I mean do the math coming down from
you know, four or five nanograms,
which used to be the lower limit now
to one peak of gram ten thousand twenty
thousand times.
I am almost under the theory that the
pendulum has swung maybe a little bit too
far in the other direction and that that
certainly is part of my job to the UFC.
Look, I want to catch every
intentional cheater that's out there.
I want to make sure we
have a rock solid program,
use all the latest and greatest,
you know, um, techniques to do it.
But I also want to keep an eye on it
to make sure it's being administrated
fairly. And when you're getting
down to detection of one, you know,
single digit Pika grams,
I have a concern that what kind of level
of sensitivity we're talking about.
Are we going to talk about environmental
contamination where you walk, you know,
through a room and somebody has just
opened a container of something and
there's, you know, minuscule
powders in the air.
There are documented cases that some of
the regularly prescribed prescription
drugs, specifically diuretics,
are getting in water supplies
in some areas. You know,
you get a lot of old people on
them that flushed their old, um,
pills down the toilet.
There's documented cases of it getting
into the water supply and being
detectable at that peak and gram
level. So you've gotta be really,
really careful about that.
And I think, you know,
this case exemplifies that you Sada and,
and really the world anti-doping agency
world and community are aware of that.
Um, you know, with greater sensitivity
and testing, in my opinion,
because you know,
makes greater responsibility to be
objective and look fairly at what really
we're doing here when we're
detecting in that small amount.